APPROPRIATIONS ARE NOW COME TO
ORDER. GOOD AFTERNOON AND
WELCOME TO THE HEARING ON
APPROPRIATIONS IN RESPONSE THE
COVE IN NINETEEN EMERGENCY IN A
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE ARE GOING TO
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
IN IN HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING
AND FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO OUR NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. BERLINGUER COMMITTEE
HEARING HERE IN THE CAPITAL AND
THERE ARE NO COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY TODAY TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WE WILL
BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICES. FOR THOSE WISHING TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT TO PARTICIPATE
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR QUERY
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I'LL ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBERS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE THREE AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS SEVEN OH FIVE SIX NINE OH
NINE. LET ME SAY THAT AGAIN THE
PHONE NUMBERS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
THREE AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
SEVEN ZERO FIVE SIX. NINE ZERO
NINE. FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW THE TELECONFERENCES THAT
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE FOR COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU BE PROMPTED BY MODERATOR.
TO DIAL ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION. PRESS THIS
ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR THE OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER. THERE
MAY BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL
WAIT IN THE QUEUE. FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU'LL BE
ON MUTED AND YOU'LL BE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU. VERY CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ANY FEEDBACK YOU MUST
MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AND ENCOURAGE YOU
TO MUTE THE DEVICE THAT YOU'RE
LISTENING WHEN YOU TALK.
OBVIOUSLY I MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTION MUTED. IT'S ALSO A
GOOD TIME TO REMIND EVERYONE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY THAT THIS
IS A FISCAL COMMITTEE. SO
PLEASE LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY THE
PHYSICAL ASPECTS OF THE BILL.
YOUR TESTIFYING ON AND PLEASE
REFRAIN FROM REPEATING PRIOR
TESTIMONY A RE LITIGATING THE-
POLICY MERITS OF YOUR BILLS
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS AND THE CONDUCTOR
HEARINGS AND IS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIME FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS
OR TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. TODAY WE WILL ALL ONLY
BE HEARING ONE URGENT BILL AB
THREE THREE ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES SAWYER.
THAT NEEDS TO PASS OFF THE
FLOOR BEFORE A RECESS. WE'VE
HEARD FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND THEY DO NOT HAVE A
FILE ON THE BILL AND WILL BE
NOT PARTICIPATING TODAY. BEFORE
WE HEAR PRESENTATION ON THE
MATTER LET'S. ESTABLISH A
QUORUM SO MISTER CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
PORTANTINO HERE. PORTANTINO
HERE SENATOR BATES. BATES HERE
SENATOR BRADFORD. BRADFORD HERE
SENATOR JONES. SENATOR
KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER HERE CENTER
LAYERED HERE. LAYERED HERE
SENATOR MCCASKEY. CASKEY HERE
WITH SIX MEMBERS PRESENT. WE
HAVE A QUORUM. ALL RIGHT SORRY
ABOUT THAT- WE HAVE A QUORUM
MISTER JONES SAWYER WOULD YOU
PLEASE COME UP AND TELL US BUT
AB THREE THREE ONE. AS
PREVIOUSLY STATED ON THIS IS
OUR ONLY AGENDA ITEM IT'S AN
URGENCY BILL. SO TELL US ABOUT
YOUR BILL. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE
TO. START BY TAKING THE CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL
THEIR HARD WORK IN HELPING ME
AND MY OFFICE GET AB THREE
THREE ONE HEARD BEFORE YOU
TODAY. THIS BILL REMAX THE
CRIME OF ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT
AND THE OPERATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
PROPERTY CRIMES TASK FORCE.
UNTIL JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
SIX. SINCE WE PASSED THE
ORIGINAL VERSION OF THIS LAW
BACK IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN. THE
CRIME OF ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT
AND THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL TASK FORCE HAVE BEEN
EFFECTIVE TOOLS AND BUSTING
RETAIL THEFT RINGS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. EVEN AS RECENTLY AS
FEBRUARY OF THIS YEAR. THIS
BILL CONTINUES STRIKE A BALANCE
BETWEEN KATHLEEN A PERVASIVE
PROBLEM. THE MOST IMPORTANT
PRESERVING THE PROGRESS WE HAVE
MADE IN PUBLIC SAFETY REFORMS.
ON TOP OF THE FIVE POINT FIVE
BILLION ALLOCATED TO REGIONAL
PROPERTY TASK FORCE. IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET AB THREE THREE
ONE MAINTAINS A VITAL TOOL THAT
HAS HELPED US. COLLECTIVELY
RECOVER MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND
PUT A STOP TO THESE ORGANIZED
RETAIL CRIME RINGS BRINGS. WITH
ME TODAY TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY
OVER THE PHONE IS STEVE
MCCARTHY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION'S. MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE. ALL RIGHT I UNDERSTAND
THAT WE HAVE STEVE MCCARTHY
FROM THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION ON THE COASTLINE SO
PLEASE Q. MUCH. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'M STEVE
MCCARTY OF THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION. OF
APPLES YOU'RE A IN A COALITION
OF GROUPS ON OUR LETTER WE ARE
PLEASED TO SUPPORT AB THREE
THIRTY ONE. WITH REGARD TO THE
FISCAL IMPACT OF THIS BILL
WOULD LIKE TO NOTE THAT PRIOR
TO THE PANDEMIC. ORGANIZED
RETAIL CRIME WAS ESTIMATED AT
THREE TO FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY IN CALIFORNIA. AT THAT
SCALE THE LOSS OF WHAT WOULD
HAVE BEEN LEGITIMATE SALES TO
THE UNDERGROUND WOULD ALSO MEAN
AS MUCH AS FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS. IN LOST SALES TAX FOR
STATE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. WE ARE
PLEASED TO SEE THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE
LEGISLATURE- CREATED FIVE AND
HALF MILLION TO C. H. P. AND
ANOTHER ONE HUNDRED FORTY NINE
THOUSAND TO DOJ FOR SUPPORT OF
THIS PROGRAM. LAST YEAR THE TOP
COURSES AT NOBLE NOTABLE
SUCCESS IN SHUTTING DOWN SOME
OF THESE THAT WORKS IN
COLLABORATION WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN OUR RETAILERS.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO BUILDING ON
THAT SUCCESS. PLEASE SUPPORT
THIS EXTENSION WILL TASK FORCE
AS WELL AS THE ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT STATUTE. WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB THREE THIRTY ONE.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT THAT IS
OUR ONLY PRIMARY WITNESS- WILL
NOW GO TO THE PHONE LINE. FOR
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IT'S YOUR OPPORTUNITY
FOR- NOBLE LOOKING FORTY TWO OH
THREE THERE'S NO ONE ELSE HERE
RIGHT. THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY NOW WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINE- THERE ANYONE
MODERATOR WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE THREE ONE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB THREE THIRTY ONE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AND THIS
TIME. AND ONE MOMENT FOR OUR
FIRST. NINE TO TWELVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON KEVIN ANDERSON ON
BEHALF OF THE HOME DEPOT IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE TO
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU THIS
IS TREES AND SHRUBS FROM BEHALF
OF THE INTERNET ASSOCIATION AND
STRONG SUPPORT. IN ONE MOMENT
FOR A LAUGH NINE. ONE TO TEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS REX W. ONLINE ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORTERS MANY WILL MOVE
ON OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE
IN THIS ROOM WISHING TO OPPOSE
IN NO ONE COME TO THE
MICROPHONE. FROM ANY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WISHING TO OPPOSE
FIGHTERS HEARING ON THE PHONE
LINE WHICH IN WITH THOSE AB
THREE THREE ONE TH. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB THREE
THIRTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE THIRTY
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO
ONE IN THE QUEUE. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
OPPORTUNITY SIR FINANCED IS NOT
HAVE A FILE- MISTER. JONES
ROOTS LIKE TO CLOSE. SPECULATE
FOR YOUR VOTE ALL RIGHT
QUESTION DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONSFROM ANYBODY SEEING
NO HANDS THE BILL UP. MR CASKEY
MOVE THE BILL MOVED THE BILL WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL TO
PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
MISTER CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
THIRTY ONE THE MOTIONS TO PASS
pPORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO AYE
SENATOR BATES. BATES BY SENATOR
BRADFORD. BRADFORD DODD SENATOR
JONES CENTER KAMLAGER I AM
LONGER BY SENATOR LAYERED HI
LAYERED I CENTER BY CAL SKI HI
MY COUNTY ARE HAS SIX GOALS.
YOUR BILL I SIX VOTES IT'S OUT
WILL GIVE MISTER JONES HE'S NOT
HERE. JUST. THE WILL OF THIS
BILL IS OUT SIX ZERO THIS
MEETING IS ADJOURNED THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND CHAIRS.
AND.